comment faire pour redonner au château
de versailles tout son faste et pour le
faire redécouvrir aux touristes tel
qu'il était au temps de la splendeur du
roi soleil
une vaste opération de rénovation est en
cours récemment l'un des plus beaux
plafond de versailles était totalement
élevé le chantier a mobilisé une
quinzaine de restaurateurs pendant deux
ans nathalie et père christian welter il
y a longtemps vécu un roi qui vous lui
laissez de son règne de sa gloire une
image éternelle et indestructible ainsi
naquit versailles un palais grandiose
que louis xiv mis quarante ans à faire
construire trois siècles plus tard ils
sont trois millions de visiteurs à
franchir chaque année les portes du
château un musée colossal qu'il faut
sans cesse entretenir
nous sommes ici au salon d'hercule au
lieu de festivités avant la révolution
le plafond chef-d'oeuvre de françois
lemoine vient tout juste d'être
restaurée le résultat est superbe à la
hauteur de deux années d'efforts pour
accroître le débit donc les couleurs
certaines ballif égèrement d'autres
réponses
en gros c'est la même harmonie les mêmes
couleurs mais on sait qu'il ya des
différences ne puissiez les craquelures
il ya des couleurs qui réapparaissent
plus que d'autres donc il faut compter
avec ce qu'on appelle la pectine et le
changement des couleurs avec les temps
au total 13 restaurateurs ont oeuvré sur
ce chantier de près de 500 mètres carrés
à 15 mètres au dessus du sol
menuisier peintre d'horreur tous ont
travaillé avec ferveur sur le nettoyage
de la peinture ternie par la saleté et
dénaturée par de nombreux vernis une
opération de grande envergure mais qui
s'inscrit dans une politique de
restauration menés par versailles depuis
une cinquantaine d'années de nombreux
meubles ont ainsi été retrouvées
racheter et replacer sur leur lieu
d'origine
petit à petit le palais retrouve son
faste d'antan mais pour cela il faut du
temps et beaucoup d'argent
l'installation coûte cher par définition
parce qu'il faut en reprendre
complètement les décors tels qu'ils nous
sont parvenues qui sont évidemment à ses
musées assez qu'ils ont vécu donc il
faut qu'on fasse des études préalables
qui montrent l'état exact je dirais de
décor et puis après il faut qu'on
finisse cette restauration qui sont
toujours à plusieurs millions selon les
pièces heureusement le mécénat est là et
c'est en général à 50% que l'état et lui
se partagent l'addition une aide
providentielle qui permet autant aversa
et de s'embellir qu'à certaines
entreprises d'améliorer leur image de
marque
prochain grand projet la restauration de
la célèbre galerie des glaces dont la
longueur 73 mètres laissent présager un
chantier très coûteux on parle de 70
millions de francs pour l'heure le
généreux donateur n'a pas encore été
trouvé